these are the top 5 most overpowered
devil fruits in one piece starting with
the brush fruit yep yep that's right
we're already starting with a shocker
and while this fruit may surprise many
of you let's take a look at just how
incredible those Powers really are in
chapter 754 the samurai kanduro first
demonstrate this fruit's powers to put
it simply the fruit allows its user to
produce ink and then anything that is
painted with this ink can come alive and
this ability makes it probably the most
adaptable fruit in the entire story I
mean need some food just paint it need a
way to fly easy need an overpowered
destructive force of nature a robot that
can scale the grand line one five Dragon
kaido's raining down destruction on the
battlefield literally anything is
possible now of course as one big caveat
the strength of these creations does
seem to depend on the skill of the
artist but in the hands of someone like
kanjiro who is really good at Art this
fruit is truly incredible although we
initially thought that the Creations
were weak to water we later then learned
that they are not which makes them even
more ridiculously powerful and we've
even seen kanjuro create walking talking
clones of other people and while these
clones seem like they can't take much
damage if the user is creative they can
still be devastating in battle and these
Powers even allowed kanjiro to create
this creepy looking giant blob which set
the entirety of kaido's castle on fire
and threatened to take out every single
person fighting on the island also this
video is sponsored by lootboy if you're
into either anime or game switch let's
be honest you are otherwise what are you
even doing watching this video and you
haven't heard of it lootboy is a free
app on the app store Google Play the app
gallery and even the PC with over 10
million registered users worldwide and
an impressive 4.6 star rating on Google
Play what does it do well the system
behind lootboy is pretty simple you get
to open booster packs like these here
that contain all kinds of awesome weep
style prizes you can see me just opening
a bunch of premium shown in packs and
getting a ton of awesome stuff with some
highlights including 12 months of
Crunchyroll premium Amazon gift cards PC
games and most importantly a ton of
Shonen and one piece related prizes now
you might be wondering Manu how can I
get these packs well basically there are
two ways you can either take the
shortcut and just use real money where
you will get two packs for less than two
bucks or if you have more time on your
hands you can complete in-app quests to
earn diamonds and then pay for the packs
that way all you need to do is click the
link in the description use this code
right here and lootboy will send you a
community loot pack with diamonds loot
coins and other great stuff when you
redeem it and now back to the video and
on top of all that we don't even know
yet if conjuro actually awakened his
fruit or not I mean since awakened
fruits usually affect their environment
and this one did not seem to do so there
is a decent chance that this fruit has
not even reached its full potential and
has an even more overpowered level that
we never even got to see one possibility
for an Awakening could for example be
allowing the user to turn the
environment into ink which can then be
used to create anything or maybe the
user can even awaken different brushes
so that anyone who has one can bring
paintings to life either way the brush
fruit feels like one of the most
critically underrated and insanely
adaptable devil fruits in the story and
if you are surprised by the brush food
making it into this top five here then
you won't believe what fruits are at
number one and two on this list and
still it might be nothing compared to
the terrifying and truly god-like
life-warping powers of the Soul fruits
in chapter 835 we get an explanation for
how this fruit works by its current user
big mom basically the fruit allows the
user to manipulate the soul also known
as lifespan of other people and oneself
she can take the lifespan under certain
conditions and then turn other objects
into living conscious beings use using
this stolen lifespan like I said she is
literally creating life and like the
other fruits on this list it isn't
simply overwhelmingly powerful in battle
it also has many other mind-bending uses
that make this fruit truly special as I
mentioned Beekman uses the soul food to
bring objects to life those are then
called homies which can move around and
act independently but they are also
mostly forced to obey her commands these
Homies Still retain some personality and
memories from the person whose solely
originally were created with so let's
look at some examples of just how broken
this ability truly is big mom basically
on her Islands to protect her home from
intruder
she can animate food and water she also
used her own soul to create special
homies as we get to see with Zeus
Prometheus Napoleon and Hira which
fly and basically use elemental power
such as fire and lightning kind of
copying a bunch of other devil fruits so
basically the user can create life as
long as they have soul available to use
nonetheless there are some limitations
to these powers for one big mom is only
able to steal life span from people who
either freely offer it or people who are
afraid of her now naturally most people
are scared of big mom but we don't know
if this is a rule for the devil fruit or
only for big mom herself for example
could someone else with the fruit steal
life span from someone they love or
someone who is weak in addition Souls
can't be infused into corpses or other
living people and the homies are also
somewhat independent and can even betray
their user if they have enough
motivation for it or like we saw with
nami if someone has a weaver card of the
soul fruit user and soul can also be
stolen once it is extracted from someone
else and we've actually seen one other
person use this fruit as well mother
caramel before big mom
um ate her and she also created a home
from fire named Pandora which is ironic
because she kind of opened Pandora's box
with big mom
you get it and while big mom was never
confirmed to be awakened it is possible
that the Awakening of this devil fruit
is actually these dark blobs that we see
on whole cake Island here now these
blobs were created by big mom and are
able to gather lifespan from people who
offer it and so without a doubt the soul
fruit is super powerful and adaptive
able to create devastating weapons bring
objects to life and even transform
entire Islands to match the desires of
its user which is just insanely
overpowered but doesn't even come close
to this literal God fruit that broke the
entire one piece fandom when it was
revealed in chapter 1044 the mythical
Zone human devil fruit model sun god
Nika and of course this one had to be on
this list how could it not you might or
might not be aware that many previous
top devil fruit videos have never
actually included Luffy's rubber fruit
because honestly it's not that great but
since chapter 1044 when we first see
Luffy's Awakening and are told that this
fruit is actually a mythical Zone this
fruit has become one of the most
overpowered and strongest in the entire
story not only does this fruit turn the
user's body into Rubber and all the
crazy shenanigans that we've seen Luffy
do with that but upon Awakening they are
able to freely manifest their entire
imagination into the world remember all
those crazy things that you imagine
doing as a kid well Luffy can do all of
that in just a short time since his
reveal we've seen Luffy turn people and
objects into rubber he can catch
lightning punch with fire create actual
goggles out of his hair who knows maybe
he'll even be able to imitate other
devil fruits in the future as well which
to a certain degree he already is doing
and all of this of course is on top of
having Incredible strength and endurance
as a Zone fruit user now one downside of
the fruit is that using these Powers is
probably costing Luffy his lifespan
we're actually being told this by many
of his opponents and can even see him
grow incredibly weak and old whenever
he's using a new power however beside
this weakness we don't even know the
true limitations or even the ultimate
possibilities and Powers off this devil
fruit so do make sure to subscribe if
you want to stay in the loop and this
devil fruit is another one where the
powers are good on their own but they
are significantly enhanced by the person
using this fruit and in this case Luffy
is of course a perfect match for the
fruit because he can fully utilize his
joyful spirits and his Limitless
imagination which is probably the reason
that he was the first person to awaken
it in over 800 years but even as
ridiculously overpowered as the Nico
fruit is you'll probably be surprised to
hear that it still Falls quite short of
the reality bending powers of the number
two fruit on this list a fruit that you
probably didn't have on your radar but
it is easily taking the second place for
this video and actually not for the
reasons that you might think and that is
Bartholomew Kuma's paw fruit and I can
almost guarantee that in chapter 484
when this food was introduced that no
one could have imagined the Absurd
capabilities of this power because when
this fruit is eaten the user's hands
grow these pop hats which can repel
anything and I mean anything yeah you
have the classic things that you think
about swords range attack punches
bullets and that is nice and all but it
is hardly the limit of its true power we
saw beckons for labark and sabaori that
the user can actually launch people
across the world to wherever they want
they can compress air to make a bomb and
even more mind-blowing is that it can
actually repel intangible Concepts such
as pain and as we just learned recently
memories and Imagination and probably
stuff like personality and so on and so
forth as well and this is of course
where the true power of this fruit truly
lies if it can truly repel these
intangible Concepts then it might well
be the way that some devil fruits are
created in the first place something
that is hinted at in the story heavily I
mean the genius scientist Dr vegapunk
tells us that devil fruits were born of
people's desires so could it be possible
that Kuma or a person from the past used
his devil fruit to repel a person's
desire in order to create a new devil
fruit Mega Punk hints strongly at the
fact that he used Kuma's fruit to create
the artificial devil fruits that he was
able to make as well and so how insane
would that be if you desire to be a soft
bouncy pillow perhaps Kuma can push out
your desire and put it into a devil
fruit you want to be a mythical unicorn
well here you go there may be some
limits that we do not know of yet but so
far this just seems like the most
Limitless crazy ability in the entire
story for example could the user even
repel their own pain because this could
basically let them heal themselves
limitlessly whenever they want could
they repel a person's age to make them
younger their personality to change who
they are I mean truly this fruit is so
incredibly overpowered and I personally
can't wait to learn more about it along
with the number one fruit coming up next
but before we get there here are some
honorable mentions that just barely
missed out on this top five for one if I
had made this list before 2022 I
certainly would have had lost of me on
my list as well I mean the user
basically becomes a God within their
room area and this little girl's hobby
fruit is another insane power as she can
literally turn anyone she touches into a
little toy slave with everyone
forgetting about them also missing out
are some of the most destructive fruits
in one piece that you probably thought
of like the magma fruit the Tremor fruit
the light and darkness fruits and even
kaido's mythical fish food which allows
him to unleash the elemental powers of a
dragon however we are ranking the top 5
devil fruits that are way too
overpowered for what they originally
were supposed to be and all of these
fruit I just listed do pretty much
exactly what you would think that they
do make stuff go boom but even still you
might be surprised to learn that despite
how incredibly powerful all of these
fruits I just named are none of them
even come close to the insanely
overpowered abilities of number one and
uh yeah it's time to discuss the brain
fruit okay okay okay give me a second
here in chapter 1066 we see the famous
Dr vegapunk for the very first time in a
flashback on the ruins of the scholar
Island O'Hara now we've always known
that vegapang was a genius but it
completely shocked everyone to find out
that he was the user of the newly
introduced brain fruits and just one
chapter later we learned that its main
power is the ability to instantly
memorize information and limitlessly
store all that that knowledge in its
user's head uh okay and while at first
glance this may not directly be the best
fighting devil fruit it is so incredibly
overpowered based on the effects that it
has on the one piece World overall and I
will actually go so far as to argue that
there is literally no one in the story
who has changed the current one-piece
world as much as Dr vegapug has and
while they do know that he was in fact
born a genius the brain fruit is what
truly allowed him to change the world
first of all Mega Punk designed the sea
prism line self-propelled ships which
allow the Marines to cross the comb belt
safely and without being interrupted and
while this may not seem like a big deal
remember that the world is separated by
these stretches of calm seas and the red
line and basically if someone wants to
go from one to the other blues or the
grand line they have to go through
reverse Mountain climb the red line or
risk sailing through the comb belt and
being eaten by a giant sea monster in
other words allowing the world
government to just casually access each
part of the world world is a massive
strategic Advantage every normal person
and pirate would die for because it
would allow them to control the world
and this was all thanks to vegapang's
Scientific genius and the Brain fruits
but the ships are only the beginning so
let's take a look at all the insane
fighting forces that vegapunk has
created with the help of his fruits he
made giant robots armies of super
powered cyborgs and the Sarah theme
which are these nearly Invincible
Genetically Enhanced clones I mean
seriously who in the entire world could
stand up to all of these ridiculous
battle weapons that vegapunk has created
up to this point and of course even more
impressive is vegapunk's Research into
the devil fruits and the void Century he
has successfully cloned other Zone and
paramecia type devil fruits like the
swim fruit the love fruit and even
kaido's mythical dragon fruit so if he
has a whole stockpile of other devil
fruits just imagine the army that he
could possibly create and honestly with
his brain powers and enough time I'm
sure he could easily come up with even
more weapon happens to even counter
devil fruit abilities in the first place
and while many of these advancements
were possible because of the unique
combination of the brain fruit and
vegapunk's genius I think it is fair to
say that even a normal person who ate
this fruit would have the potential to
become a Super Genius if they decided to
study enough and of course we also want
to talk about what a possible Awakening
could look like other reality warping
paramecia Awakenings that we've seen
like lost Croom or kids magnetism have
allowed the user to Grant Powers off the
devil fruit to a part of the environment
so vegapunk this could mean that he is
able to gain the memories and knowledge
by touching other people or objects in
the world thereby increasing the
knowledge that he could gather even more
so when you truly think about the
Limitless powers of Science and
knowledge that you can have with this
single devil fruit there is not one out
there that even comes close to reaching
this level of overpowered but if you
want to prove me wrong and find an even
more op fruit that no one has thought
about make sure to check out this video
right here where I explain every single
devil fruit in one please thanks for
watching